hey guys this is Vadim with max sack and
welcome to our video quality comparison
between the pixel for the iPhone 11 Pro
and the Galaxy Note 10.1 right here
recording at 30fps at their maximum
resolutions interestingly the pixel
cannot shoot 4k selfie video at 4k at
all while the other two phones can size
the HDR right in the back we've got
those really bright clouds and the
iPhone actually gets extended dynamic
range at 4k 30 so it definitely looks
really nice and we're also recording the
audio for all three phones so you guys
can hear me switch between those and
just let me know how they sound down in
the comments below so what we're gonna
start off with is walking stabilization
on the front side so you guys can see
which one has the better stabilization
I'm walking on some rough terrain some
rocks right now and what they call
misspell and I'm gonna start running so
let me know which one does better at
stabilization while running and the nice
thing about the iPhone is that you can
shoot at 60 frames per second on the
selfie camera which you cannot do on
either of the other phones and it even
does it at 4k so 4k 60 which is insane
so as you guys can see if you want to
slow down your selfie video the iPhone
is the one that's going to look very
smooth while the other two are going to
be very choppy and on top of that the
iPhone actually gets 1080p 120 fps slow
fees which is a step above
now with the Samsung Galaxy Note 10 you
could actually do live focused video so
it does add a pretty cool blur effect in
the back but it's not perfect I'm really
excited for when they do finally get
this down maybe next year or the year
after that but it's definitely can be
really nice for vlogging
now switching over to the rear cameras
and shooting at 60fps and actually
slowing it down to 30 the pixel can only
do it at 1080p instead of 4k like on the
other two so it definitely is lacking
quality it also looks a little bit
desaturated at times as well now for
wide stabilization they all do a really
good job except it looks like the pixel
and the note do have a little bit more
noticeable micro stutter but you don't
get on the iPhone 11 and it definitely
does
better job at running compared to the
other two now using the telephoto lens
it looks like the pixel doesn't do as
well as the other two phones which seem
to be a draw between those soon the
iPhone and the no also have ultra wide
lenses with digital stabilization it's
surprising to see how it does better
than the pixel fours optical image
stabilization on the wide lens the note
10 does have super steady stabilization
which only works at 1080p and it crops
in a little bit but it does do a better
job than the other two testing flaring
against the Sun the iPhone does have the
best dynamic range and it also has a
good amount of contrast as well compared
to the other two those same differences
are even more visible in this clip
especially the dynamic range and if we
crop in to look a little bit closer you
can tell that the iPhone does have more
detail compared to the other two as well
here's another shot showing off the
ultra wide lenses on the iPhone in the
note 10 that give a really cool looking
perspective and it's interesting that
even with the ultra wide lenses the
dynamic range is better than on the
pixel force wide lens this year is a
very tough dynamic range test and it
looks like the note 10 is not doing as
well as the other phones so it's between
the pixel and the iPhone 11 Pro but if
we take a closer look at the clouds the
iPhone does keep better colors in the
sky and has better dynamic range now
let's test the autofocus speed on each
of these phones and you can notice when
Max gets back up the iPhone actually
catches the autofocus sooner than the
other two and running this test one more
time we can see that the pixel actually
takes quite a bit longer than the other
phones to catch focus and at this moment
the colors are a little bit too cool on
the iPhone which I don't like but the
dynamic range is much better than on the
note now in this shot I filmed against
the Sun to catch the flaring and from
the looks of it it looks like the pixel
four actually did the best job of
holding the details in the face instead
of having it all gray because of the
flaring in this test I held the camera
rig as steady as I possibly could so we
can test out the long-range detail by
cropping in and it's interesting that
the note 10 plus has a lot of jitter and
the pixel 4 doesn't do that well for
dynamic range so the iPhone looks the
best
now using the telephoto lenses at 6
times zoom on each phone we still see
the same jitter on the note 10 and for
some reason the pixel 4 looks really
soft all
like it's not even using the telephoto
lens and using the wide lens with a
6-time crop instead and then we max out
the zoom on each phone which is eight
times on the pixel six times on the
iPhone and ten times on the note 10
which makes those jitters look much
worse than they looked before now let's
test audio zoom
[Music]
now testing 240fps slow motion the
iPhone is lacking contrast so it doesn't
really look detailed well that pixel 4
looks over contrasted so I think the
note 10 looks the best here the note 10
also has a seven twenty P 960 FPS mode
which honestly does not look good at all
but it's really nice that you still have
that mode now moving on a low light the
iPhone has way too much noise in this
image so I'm gonna go with the note 10
because it's shooting at 4k and has much
more detail than on the pixel now for
the rear facing camera the pixel turn
the yellow light bulb white which is
really weird and the note 10 competitors
a light bulb so the iPhone does have the
best HDR and we see the same differences
on the telephoto lens with a lot of
artifacting and noise on the pixels
image in a lack of dynamic range on the
note alright guys thanks for watching
that was our video quality comparison of
the pixel for the iPhone 11 pro and vino
10 plus so let us know down in the
comments which one you thought was
better make sure to click that circle
above to subscribe and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]